well right now president trump is
continuing to claim that there is
widespread voter fraud here in nevada
but his campaign
and state republicans have yet to show
more than several isolated cases
the i-team's david charns looked into
that today and david so far there are
just
two cases where ballots were sent in the
names of people who'd already passed
away right so joe just
mentioned that a bit we found those two
cases of someone who died being on clark
county's voter rolls
then being sent to mail in ballot and
then having it returned the question
right now is
who signed those ballots and sent them
in well this morning president trump
claiming quote there is a cesspool of
fake voters here in nevada though he
didn't provide any evidence
twitter actually flagged the tweet with
some of the i-team's previous reporting
state republicans alleging thousands
voted illegally here in nevada
but all evidence that's been shown to us
and what's been even sent to
officials in the up in carson city
have said that it's been heavily
redacted so they haven't been able to do
their job so this is what we can confirm
to you this is what we found today
this is what comes up when you search
one voter who died in 2017
but a ballot was cast in his name that
ballot went out october 9th it came back
halloween
clark county officials say it appears
that ballot was signed by a family
member
who herself did not vote now a second
voter also died in 2017.
she had a ballot cast in her name hers
went out also on the ninth came back the
monday before election day
all these cases forwarded to the
attorney general and secretary of state
the ag's office telling us this
afternoon they have yet to receive
any formal complaints in the information
they have seen
has heavily redacted language now keep
in mind right now the spread between
president-elect biden and president
trump is about 65
000 votes here in nevada and we are
talking about
two votes here nonetheless fraud coming
up new at six o'clock hear from the
husband
of one of those two cases his wife died
three years ago
from breast cancer i'm david sharns 8
news now